Speaker 1: Hey, everybody, I'm Ferring Cousins
in for David Pakman, and this is the David
Pakman Show, we've got all kinds of great
stuff coming up today, the latest on Afghanistan,
of course, some covid updates for you and
even a little bit of insight into what is
happening with Republican Congressman Matt
Gates and that investigation and some other
problems that he's having right here where
I'm sitting in Florida's 1st Congressional
District.
But let's kick things off.
Obviously, still the biggest news in the world
right now, Afghanistan.
Things getting worse, of course.
And here's something interesting that's happened.
And this was actually pointed out by Dave
Weigel of The Washington Post, where Weigel
pointed out over the weekend that a Web page
on the RNC official website seems to have
disappeared.
And that Web site or Web page, I guess, was
the page talking about Donald Trump's historic
peace deal, as they called it, with the Taliban
with regards to Afghanistan.
If you go to that page now, there's just a
404 page not found error because apparently
the Republican National Committee doesn't
want people seeing that they're promoting
that ridiculous peace deal that Donald Trump
allegedly worked out.
And there's a couple of reasons for that,
too.
So let's dove right into those.
First and foremost, they don't want any attention
on what Donald Trump did as president with
regard to Afghanistan.
And let's be honest, there's a lot but the
peace deal that he allegedly had worked out
with the Taliban that was signed in February
of twenty twenty is the biggest thing they
don't want people to remember.
And that's because once you dig down into
the details of this so-called peace deal,
you realize how horrible it actually was.
And the biggest problem with this peace deal
is that it completely excluded.
The Afghan government.
No leaders from Afghanistan were involved
in the drafting of this and the protections
that the United States agreed to with the
Taliban did not extend.
To the actual Afghanistan government.
The deal only pertained to U.S. troops and
our NATO allies in the country that the Taliban
would not attack them in exchange for the
United States agreeing to leave the country
within 14 months.
But nowhere, not any part of that agreement
did the Taliban say, oh, by the way, we won't
promise to not attack the Afghanistan government.
Apparently, that was just a major oversight.
Of this peace deal and of course, as soon
as the United States leaves, the Taliban goes
and overthrows the government of Afghanistan.
So, yeah, it's not surprising that they would
want that Web page removed from existence
because they're boasting about it, talking
about, look what Donald Trump did, bringing
peace to the Middle East with this historic
deal.
Nope, nope, another total failure by Donald
Trump.
Another reason, though, that they do not want
this page out there in existence and I think
this is probably the bigger one, is because
they want all the focus right now to be on
Joe Biden.
That is the goal, make this Biden's failure.
Make this all about his decision to remove
Trump from our troops from Afghanistan, ignoring
the fact that even just a couple months ago,
Donald Trump was, you know, screaming at the
top of his lungs to tell Joe Biden to get
the troops out of Afghanistan.
But they have to frame this as Biden's failure,
because that's the new talking point in immerge
fast, it emerged quick and based on what we're
seeing in the media, tends to be the sticking
narrative at this point that this is all Joe
Biden's fault.
And let's obviously be clear about this, that's
not the case.
This is the fault of four different administrations,
but if you had to lay the blame at anybody's
feet, that blame is going to be squarely at
the feet of George W. Bush.
And I will get more into that in just a little
bit.
But the talking point from the RNC, from Republican
officials, from elected officials, from Donald
Trump himself, is all about Joe Biden being
a catastrophic failure and they're hoping
that they can ride this all the way through
the midterms.
You know, I pointed out yesterday on the program
that the Republicans have had a hell of a
time getting any kind of talking point to
stick about.
Joe Biden.
They have crafted all these narratives.
Fox News has tested them out.
And even Fox News at one point was getting
frustrated because nothing they were saying
or using to attack Biden was resonating with
the audience.
Well, this is something that would resonate.
And again, as I mentioned, fair or not, Biden
was the president when this happened.
So if people are going to blame somebody,
they are going to blame him.
I don't agree with that assessment at all,
but I also live in reality.
I've been doing this long enough, you know,
coming up on two decades at this point, we
know how these things play out.
We know where the blame is going to go and
we know the talking points that the Republicans
are going to use.
And one of the main reasons we know that is
because we're literally already seeing it
happen on social media, in the corporate media.
Republicans are pushing this nonstop and they
want to keep it that way.
They want the focus to remain on Joe Biden
because that's the message.
Joe Biden couldn't keep Afghanistan safe.
And if he can't keep them safe, how's he going
to keep you safe?
We're already starting to see the narrative
crop up of, oh, what is Taliban taking over
Afghanistan mean for terror attacks here in
the United States?
Several outlets started reporting stories
like that on Monday.
They're already trying to pose this as what
is the significant threat that this will pose
to us here in the United States, can Biden
even keep us safe now?
We're right back into that same post 9/11
mentality where every time you turn around,
there's a boogeyman being pushed on you by
these politicians who are using it to scare
you into submission, to scare you into voting
for them.
And that's what we're starting to see now,
it's disgusting, but again, it's one hundred
percent predictable.
This is how they operate.
This is the way they craft their narrative.
This is the way they sell it to the public.
And unfortunately, the Republican Party is
very, very good at selling these narratives
in a way that the Democratic Party can only
ever dream of being.
On issue after issue, Republicans get out
front on the messaging and that is what sticks,
and then the Democrats have to come from behind
trying to defend it, debunk it, refute it,
whatever it is.
And they're never on the offensive.
And this narrative has already been lost.
It's already been lost.
So, again, whether you agree with Biden's
decision to pull the troops out, I do.
Whether you disagree with it doesn't matter.
The narrative that the media has already captured
is that this is a failure of the Biden administration
and Republicans are going to ride that all
the way to the twenty, twenty two midterms